must be dragonglass dragon the next is
called obsidian what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season 8 Q&A video I know
some of you still have a lot of
questions you wanted answered so I
figured I would do another one of these
videos last night I made a post asking
everyone to leave me some questions so I
picked the questions that I saw with the
most likes then I picked a few other
ones that didn't have any just to mix it
up I only left that post up for about an
hour because I wanted to get started on
this video right away so with that being
said let's begin this first question is
from yo mama is fat what do you think
the horn Sam found in season 2 will be
used for if at all well according to the
legend this horn has the power to be
able to wake the Giants and bring down
the wall but both of these things have
already happened without the horn being
blown the wildlings have had Giants
since the show began in the night King
brought down the wall with Vasari on so
if they would introduce this horn again
in season 8 there are really only two
things I think they could possibly do
before I say what those two things are I
have to give a spoiler warning because I
could potentially spoil something next
season so if you do not want to know I
would recommend fast-forwarding the
video just look at the clock on the
screen and skip to that time some
filming news came out last week and
apparently during one of the episodes
next season someone will blow a horn at
Winterfell now this horn could just be a
signal warning every one of the enemy
approaching or it could be the Horn of
winter which Sam did find during season
two in the books Sam took this horn with
him to the Citadel but we haven't seen
him with it in the show since he found
it but he could still have it with him
and it could be the horn that will be
blown at Winterfell Sam did take a bunch
of old restricted books from the Citadel
and he may find out exactly what the
horn is used for or brain could find out
in one of his visions since the wall
already came down and the Giants are
already awake then I think this horn
could wake something else
this horn could possibly wake up the old
kings of winter and the crypts of
Winterfell they could all possibly have
a connection
considering they all have winter in
their title it is called the Horn of
winter in the Kings below Winterfell are
called the kings of winter so maybe it
will wake them up but this horn could
also work like the dragon binder in the
books euron greyjoy has a horn he said
he found in Valerio he said his horn has
the power to control dragons so I think
the Horn of winter could be very similar
but instead of controlling dragons maybe
it can control the night king or his
army you have to keep in mind when Sam
found this horn he did find it with
other weapons that are used to defeat
the others so maybe this horn is a
weapon as well and it can be used to
control whatever the night king is
controlling or maybe the horn is so loud
it can crack and shatter ice it could
have the power to shatter all of the
White Walkers I know that might sound a
bit tinfoil E but that's just my opinion
I really don't see it having any other
purpose but to be used against the night
King the next question is from tape if
Danny's vision of the burnt throne room
is foreshadowing then why is the
seven-pointed stars still behind the
throne that in searcy get rid of that
and put a Lannister lion there yes
Cersei did change the pointed star to
Elena store lion so technically if
Danny's vision was a glimpse of the
future than it should have had a lion
there as well I totally agree with that
but don't let that deter you in my
opinion it's just a continuity error
when the showrunners filmed this scene
back in season 2 I don't think they
thought about the pointed star behind
the throne at that time they probably
didn't think they would be changing it
to a lion and you have to keep in mind
they filmed that scene almost five years
ago the show has made so many continuity
errors lately I wouldn't put too much
thought into this so let me give you an
example
dragonglass should not be able to kill
white's back in the early seasons the
only way to kill White's was with fire
in fact in the book Sam stabs a white
with dragonglass nearly a dozen times
and it doesn't affect it at all but now
all of a sudden in season seven White's
are dropping like flies with just about
any weapon touching them these are
issues with continuity within the show's
plot
and the symbol behind the throne is just
another poor example of this that's all
trust me we will see the throne-room
look just like it did in Danny's vision
next season the next question is from
Matthew and he says do you think Songza
will attempt to stage a coup right when
John and Danny arrive and she and the
Northmen find out the chemistry between
the two this is a really good question
and this is something I have talked
about at length with grey area
both of us think songs and we'll have a
major problem when John shows up with
Daenerys at his side Sansa and a few
others made it very clear how they felt
about the Targaryen 's they might not
know Daenerys but they do not trust her
or her dragons and they have a good
reason Danny's father the Mad King did
not leave a good impression on the
people of the north so I completely
understand why they would be hesitant
when it comes to accepting Daenerys as
an alliance or as their queen when John
arrives with Daenerys in her dragons the
tension in the north is going to be very
high I think we could see John bump
heads with you on Royce and even Sansa
but once the night king shows up they
aren't gonna have time for these petty
differences if they do not unite and
fight together they're not gonna survive
they need Danny's men and they need her
dragons or else they stand no chance
against the army of the Dead so with
that being said I don't think songs is
gonna take this too far she will express
how she feels and her and John are not
gonna see eye-to-eye once again but when
the war begins she will realize the
merits can be trusted
Daenerys already put her own life on the
line to save John maybe Bryan can help
Sansa understand all of this Brian can
see everything and he could explain
exactly what kind of person Daenerys is
by the things that he has seen her do or
the things she's gonna do the next
question is from night gaming do you see
the night King being bran
well Arya embrace Danny I doubt songs oh
well let me answer that first one first
do you think bran is the night king and
I'm gonna give you the short answer and
that is no bran is not the night king
but I do understand why people think
that it's not a bad theory necessarily
but I just don't think that's where
they're going to go now we'll Oriya
embrace Danny I think Arya will embrace
John and she will support John with
whatever decisions he is making
I really don't think Aria and Daenerys
will become besties but Aria will
support her because of her love for her
brother John now I know they're not
technically brother and sister but you
know what I mean they will always be
brother and sister
they have a special bond that cannot be
broken I do think Oreo will be very
surprised with all of the revelations
next season but I don't think that will
change her relationship with John
therefore Aria and Danny will get along
well enough
Aria might even come to respect Daenerys
because of how fearless she can be when
it comes to going into battle this next
question is from Andre and he said do
you think because terian is known for
reading a lot that somehow he read
something about the truth of John's
parentage and that's why he had that
look of concern as John entered Daenerys
his room that's not a bad idea Andre but
I don't think that was the case in my
opinion Tyrion gave that look for
another reason I think he was more
concerned with what this means
politically and the potential dangers it
could put Daenerys in or Tyrion may have
even felt like his own position is
slipping further and further out of his
grasp Tyrion is the hand of the Queen to
Daenerys but she has pretty much stopped
taking all of his advice and she has
even been angry with him lately now that
John has entered the picture Daenerys
has pretty much put everything to the
side to follow John and everything he
wants to do Daenerys put her own life in
danger to save John and Tyrion even told
her if she died then everything they
work for would have been for nothing and
Daenerys went anyway now that Daenerys
is falling in love with John she will be
even more inclined to doing what John
wants to do in further distancing
herself from Tyrion in his counsel I
think tyrion sees that he may be
becoming useless in Danny's eyes now
that she has John and becoming
romantically involved with someone in
the middle of two different wars is not
exactly ideal the next question is from
Tim how do you think the unsullied and
Dothraki will do fighting in a terrain
they are extremely unfamiliar in ie the
snow the ice and rocky hilly terrain I
don't think they are going to do very
well at all I have a good feeling the
unsullied and Dothraki are gonna get
slaughtered and mostly for the reasons
you just gave
the northern terrain is completely
foreign to them the unsullied in
Dothraki have never fought in winter
before and this will be one of the worst
winters on record almost 95% of the
soldiers are gonna be useless this war
will come down to a few different things
the night king his dragon his Giants and
White Walkers
and then on the other side you will have
Danny's dragons and John plus a small
group of super soldiers those will be
the main focal points of these battles
those are the X factors all of the other
soldiers who have no names will be
slaughtered it will look amazing to see
hundreds of thousands of soldiers and
whites fighting in a scene of chaos but
ultimately it will come down to the main
characters and their magical weapons
like dragons Giants dire wolves Valyrian
steel swords and things like that the
next question is from Mike Warren which
characters do you think will survive
till the end what role do you think they
will assume in forming the new world of
Westeros there are only a handful of
characters that I am confident enough to
say that I guarantee they would survive
they are mostly the characters who fall
under the cripples bastards and broken
things moniker people like Samwell Tarly
Gendry Davos Jon Snow Tyrion Lannister
and a few others that I have made videos
about they will be the characters to
survive and they will be the ones to
rebuild and restore Westeros they will
need to make new laws and put together a
Council of rollers instead of just
having one king or one queen roll over
everything they've already learned the
hard way that it doesn't work that way
if they truly want to break the wheel
then they have to change everything in
the way of living everyone was
accustomed to this next question is from
Lucas who will die Danny or John I have
been saying this for quite some time now
if one of them dies I think it will be
Daenerys I don't want to go too deep
into this because I have talked about it
before but I think the ending could be
very ironic think about it like this the
whole time Daenerys has thought she had
the rightful claim to the Iron Throne
then when her dragons finally got big
enough and her army got big enough she
comes to Westeros to claim this throne
but she soon realized she wasn't going
to take it as easily as it may have
seemed due to her strength in numbers
and in the end she never had the
rightful claim after all and she dies
before she even reaches the iron throne
then on the other hand you have the
bastard Jon Snow he never had the desire
to sit on the Iron Throne nor did he
think he would ever be in a position to
do so but then he comes to find out he
is the rightful heir to the Seven
Kingdoms but in the end he doesn't even
want it I think it may end like that
Daenerys never reaches it and John
doesn't want it I am not sure how to
pronounce this next person's name but I
will read your question do you think the
night king will unleash new forces such
as I spiders I do believe this is very
possible with only one season left I
think we could see just about anything
we didn't know the night King had giants
until season 7 so it wouldn't be that
crazy if they introduced spiders in the
next season when the great war begins we
will truly see what the night King is
fully capable of and I won't rule why
spiders out actually I hope we do see
them I think that would be very cool and
I would almost guarantee the night King
has one more surprise tucked up his
sleeve speaking of the night King and
surprises this leads me to the last
question I will answer in this video can
the night King be destroyed by Valyrian
steel or dragonglass weapons this is a
great question and this could be another
one of those surprises the night King
has up his sleeve about a year ago I
made a video about how to defeat the
night king and in that video I said it's
gonna take something much more special
than the magical weapons we have
currently seen I do not think mullerian
steel or dragon glass will kill him it's
gonna take more than that
we know the White Walkers can be killed
by those weapons but since the night
king is the most powerful of them all
then it would only make sense that it
would take more than that to stop him
besides he was made with dragonglass so
I doubt dragonglass could kill him it's
gonna take one of two things to stop him
it will need to be a dragon that kills
him or a sword like light bringer but
let me know what you think give me your
thoughts on some of the questions from
today's video I would like to see what
you have to say I want to thank all of
you for stopping by
watching the video I always appreciate
that and I also want to thank my
supporters on patreon your support truly
means a lot to me I hope everyone has a
great day I'll see you in the next one
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]